today we're trying something that's
never been done before I've made this
video and Destin has made a video on
smarter every day and we want you to
play them both at the same time so
there's a link to his video down in the
description find a way to load both of
these videos and then synchronize them
on my mark in five four three two one in
Sydney Australia we are at 34 degrees
south latitude which is the opposite
side of the world from Huntsville
Alabama so which way to the toilets
flush that is the question
The Simpsons did a whole episode based
on toilets flushing the opposite
direction in Australia plus other shows
have supposedly demonstrated this effect
so is this a real effect or not the
application of this principle to
draining water in Earth's two
hemispheres is just bunk if you try it
yourself you'll find inconsistent
results this sink sometimes drains one
way and sometimes the other way in any
container of water there's always going
to be some rotation the water is not
perfectly still and it is this rather
than the hemisphere that determines
which way the water will swirl down the
drain but what if we could eliminate all
motion from the water
I have here a five foot wide kiddie pool
actually fill the pool in the
anti-clockwise direction to be sure that
any clockwise motion we see is not due
to the way I filled the pool I've left
this water sitting here for 24 hours so
it seems like I've damped all of the
motions from the filling
I really hope this works Destin wish me
luck
I'm about to pull the plug three two one
and the pool is draining but you can't
see any motion of the water just yet to
help us see where the water is flowing
I'm going to put some food coloring in
on the four cardinal directions around
the pool
you
you can clearly see that the water is
flowing clockwise in this direction and
that makes sense because that's how it
should flow in the southern hemisphere
due to the Earth's rotation
but you can see what a tiny little
effect it is and what extraordinary
lengths I had to go to to see this
effect so really you're not going to see
it in a bathtub and you're not going to
see it in a sink or in a toilet because
there are other sources of angular
momentum that totally wash out this
effect the Coriolis effect there you
have it
it works to understand how it works
imagine a pool with one edge touching
the South Pole the pool is stationary
relative to Earth but every day it's
actually completing one full revolution
now you can see the side of the pool
furthest from the pole travels much
farther every day than the side right
next to the pole
so the outer side of the pool is moving
fastest towards the east and as you get
closer to the pole the velocity
decreases down to zero now imagine we
drain the pool water from the far side
is moving too fast relative to the drain
and so it gets out ahead whereas water
from near the pole is going too slow and
so it lags behind
so when the water approaches the drain
it swirls clockwise and this is the
reason cyclone swirl clockwise in the
southern hemisphere the higher pressure
air rushes into the eye of the storm and
just like in our pool swirls in the
direction dictated by the hemisphere and
that's the truth about toilet swirl
I definitely learned something and if
unit 2 then you should share these
videos with your friends so you should
subscribe to this guy
subscribe to Destin run every day ok yep
yep you're here
that's what we're going to do we're
going to subscribe to veritasium in mass
because it's an awesome channel oh oh
look where's the subscribe button but
seriously have you subscribed to smarter
every day yet Destin has made some of
the best videos on the internet like the
backwards bicycle Prince Rupert's drop
and what it looks like to get a tattoo
in slow motion now I've been friends
with Destin for about three years and
I'm pretty much convinced that the man
is superhuman
not only does he run a remarkably
successful YouTube channel he also has a
wife and four kids and he has a
full-time job
the man is literally a rocket scientist
and he's friends with astronauts and
when he asks them questions they answer
him from space and you are getting
smarter every day this man deserves your
subscription if you're not subscribed to
him already I don't know what you've
been doing with your life but go over to
his channel right now and subscribe to
smarter every day and trust me you will
thank me later and I want to thank you
for watching you know we have been
working on this collaboration for about
three years and it feels so good to have
it finally out there in the world I hope
you enjoyed it as much as we enjoyed
making it alright I'll see you next time
you
you